we call upon all relevant market
operators in the dairy and pig meat
sector to take their business decisions
in the light of these considerations and
to act responsibly and contribute to
restoring balance between supply and
demand that means a reduction of supply
is necessary for the markets to restore
the modalities of the application of the
voluntary Supply Management we will be
in a position to offer the opportunity
to member states to use the top of a
that they received in the sep tember
package are the new state aid which
maximum 15,000 euro per farmer per year
can we utilize those measures can be
used if member states wish in the
context of bringing about voluntary
Supply Management to compensating
farmers in the in that sense of reducing
supply of course were concerned about
the limit that there is now an
intervention was the ceilings were going
to be reached quite soon because of the
new interest in recent months in the
amount of those going into intervention
so we're doubling the ceilings for
intervention for skim milk powder from
109 thousand tons to 218 and from 60,000
tons of butter to 100,000 tons and we
these products will be managed to endure
go back in the marketplace in the same
way as the 2009 also member states have
a lot of flexibility in relation to the
rural development program they can
modify their programs once a year we can
speed up those processes very much if
they want to move money or move
assistance from one particular sector to
another one commodity or another we have
put in place new measures to make sure
that that can happen more quickly and
you know they have income stabilization
tools they have voluntary couple support
measures all of these measures are still
available to the Member States if they
choose to help a particular sector more
than another or shift money won't less
deal